♪ JACKI: WELCOME BACK TO THE BIG
SUNDAY SHOW.
WILL THERE BE ANY PAYBACK FOR
PAYPAL.
THE DIGITAL PAYMENT SYSTEM PUT
OUT A POLICY THAT WOULD ALLOW
THEM TO FINE USERS FOR MISS
INFORMATION.
LARA: SOCIAL MEDIA EXPLODED EVEN
FORMER PAYPAL EXECS.
FORMER PAYPAL PRESIDENT DAVID
MARCUS TWEETING IN PART "A
PRIVATE COMPANY NOW GETS TO
DECIDE TO TAKE YOUR MONEY IF YOU
SAY SOMETHING THEY DISAGREE
WITH?
INSANITY".
AND ELON MUSK THAT COFOUNDED PAY
PAIL AGREED AND PAYPAL SAY IT
WAS POSTED IN ERROR AND ARIZONA
SENATE CANDIDATE SAID THEY'VE
RECEIVED LARGE DONATIONS FROM
PAYPAL COFOUNDER PETER TEAL
SOUNDED OFF.
>> WE NEED TO BAN COMPANIES AT
THAT LEVEL, OF THAT SIZE,
ESPECIALLY IF THEY'RE TOUCHING
BANKING OR IN SOCIAL MEDIA,
WE'RE GOING TO BAN THESE
COMPANIES FROM DISCRIMINATING
AGAINST USERS BECAUSE OF
POLITICAL CONTENT OF THEIR
SPEECH.
THAT'S HOW WE TREAT THE PHONE
COMPANY; RIGHT?
VERIZON CAN'T GO AND LISTEN TO
YOU AND I HAVE A TELEPHONE
CONVERSATION AND SAY THAT'S TOO
CONSERVATIVE.
YOU CAN'T LET A NON--BANK LENDER
AS THE SIZE OF PAYPAL
DISCRIMINATE AND DECIDE WHAT'S
MISINFORMATION AND FINE THEM.
LARA: HERE WE GO AGAIN.
GIANNO TAKE A LISTEN TO WHAT A
CORPORATE EXECUTIVE FROM PAYPAL
HA TO SAY ABOUT THIS.
THEY SAID PAYPAL IS NOT FINING
PEOPLE FOR MISINFORMATION AND
THIS LANGUAGE WAS NEVER INTENDED
TO BE INSERTED IN OUR POLICY.
OUR TEAMS ARE WORKING TO CORRECT
OUR POLICY PAGES.
WE'RE SORRY FOR THE CONFUSION
THIS HAS CAUSED.
THEY SAY THIS IS JUST A BIG FUSS
UP, A MISTAKE.
DO YOU BUY THAT?
GIANNO: ALL LIES.
LARA: EXACTLY.
GIANNO: INSERELY.
THEY -- SINCERELY.
THEY SAID WE'RE GOING TO FINE
USERS $2500 FOR MISINFORMATION
AND THEN PUT OUT MISINFORMATION
SO WHO'S GOING TO FINE THEM IS
THE REAL QUESTION?
YOU KNOW, THIS MAKES ME THINK,
DO WE EVEN LIVE IN A FREE
COUNTRY ANYMORE?
YOU'RE REALLY GOING TO BE ASH AH
TAR OF TRUTH AND LOOK AT
PUBBISHED WRITING AND SAY YOU'RE
GOING TO FINE US?
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT'S THE TRUTH
AND I'M THINKING OF A INDIVIDUAL
THAT WAS BANNED FROM PAYPAL AND
HE'S AN EVOLUTIONARY BIOLOGIST
WRITER AND SAID THERE'S TWO
SEXES, MALE AND WOMAN, MAN AND
WOMAN, FROM THAT POINT HE WAS
BANNED AND HELD HIS MONEY FOR
180 DAYS AND THERE'S BEEN OTHER
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
DE-PLATFORMED FROM PAYPAL SO
THIS IS A TREND.
WE'RE SEEING THIS IN TWITTER,
I'LL, AND FACEBOOK AND NOW OVER
TO PAYPAL, WHICH IS A REAL NASTY
CONSIDERATION FOR A LOT OF
AMERICANS WHO HAVE MONEY THERE
AND THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY
MAY DO NEXT.
LARA: I MEAN, JACKI, WHEN THEY
TIE UP YOUR MONEY, IT'S A BIG
CONCERN FOR PEOPLE BUT TO JOHN
THAT'S POINT, BUT THEY ARE DOING
THIS.
JACKI: MILLIONS SPENT TO HELP
THE CANADIAN TRUCKERS TO HELP
WITH VACCINE MANDATES AND
HAPPENS WITH BIG TECH AND SOCIAL
MEDIA AND ONE THING IF YOU WANT
TO SUSPEND YOUR TWITTER ACCOUNT.
OKAY ACTION WE HAVE HAVE A FREE
SPEECH DISCUSSION AND NOW
PUTTING MONEY IN THE MIX AND
IT'S OUTRAGEOUS AND ALL THE
COMPANIES ARE SAYING THE
CHALANING AND VIOLATE THE
POLICIES AND POLICIES AREN'T
REALLY CLEAR.
THEY'RE AMBIGUOUS AND PEOPLE
DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY MEAN AND
THEY CAN TWIST THEM AND BEND
THEM TO FIT THEIR NARRATIVE.
THE THING I SAY ABOUT THIS ALL
THE TIME, THE ONLY WAY TO HIT
BACK AT THESE COMPANIES IS FOR
USERS TO SEE THIS IN A CASE LIKE
PAYPAL AND SAY, I'M NOT USING
YOUR PLATFORM.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT YOU MADE A
MISTAKE.
I'M NOT GOING TO GIVE YOU MY
BUSINESS.
LARA: YEAH, BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
FEEL, SEAN, LIKE THEY MADE A
MISTAKE.
FEELS LIKE THEY GOT CAUGHT AND
SAYING WAIT A MINUTE.
THIS WAS AN ERROR, WE DIDN'T
MEAN TO DO THIS.
BUT THIS IS -- WE CONTINUE TO
SEE THIS HAPPEN AND THE QUESTION
IS WHO IS THE ARBITER OF TRUTH.
I THINK ABOUT THE DISINFORMATION
CZAR THAT'S A REALLY REAL
PROSPECT NOT TOO LONG AGO.
WHERE DOES THIS GO BECAUSE IT
FEELS VERY SCARY WHERE WE'RE
HEADING?
SEAN: THERE WAS NO MISTAKE AND
DEEP CONVERSATION ABOUT DRAFTING
THAT POLICY THEY PUT OUT.
BACKLASH IS WHAT CAUSED THEM TO
CALL IT AN ERROR BUT MENTIONED
GO FUND ME.
THEY FROZE ACCOUNTS, SUSPENDED
ACCOUNTS, BUT THEY DIDN'T SEIZE
OTHER PEOPLE'S MONEY AT GO FUND
ME.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME THEY'RE
SAYING IF YOU USE -- GIANNO:
THAT'S BECAUSE IN THE U.S., THE
STATES GOT INVOLVED AND
GOVERNMENT GOT INVOLVED AND
THAT'S THE ONLY REASON WHY THEY
RELEASED THAT MONEY.
SEAN: BUT MISINFORMATION CAN
COST YOU $2500.
YOU CAN BE KICKED OFF A PLATFORM
BUT DIDN'T COST YOU $2500.
THIS IS A WHOLE NEW REALM THAT
IT'S COSTING YOU.
WHETHER IT WAS TWO SEXES OR
HUNTER BIDEN LAPTOP.
THEY'LL HOLD ALL THAT
DISINFORMATION, WHICH WE KNOW IS
TRUE AND I'M A BIG FAN OF CRYPTO
AND IT'S DE-CENTRALIZED AND
THERE WAS NO HEAD COMPANY THAT
DECIDES WHO GETS IN AND GETS OUT
WHEN IT'S OPEN TO EVERYONE WHO
WANTS TO USE IT AND I THINK THIS
IS A GREATER PUSH TO THOSE ENDS
AND PETER TEALE, ELON MUSK AND
PAYPAL, MANY IS ALSO OWNING
VENMO.
THEY REMEMBER SPEECH, THEY'RE
CONSERVATIVES AND WANT TO HEAR
THE DEBATE AND BELIEVE IN
CRYPTO.
THIS IS JUST PAYPAL AND VENMO
ARE A LITTLE STEPPINGSTONE AS WE
GET TO FREE SYSTEM OF CRYPTO.
GIANNO: INTERESTING PART, ELON
SAYS HE'S NOT A CONSERVATIVE BUT
NOW WE THINK ABOUT PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN FREE SPEECH WHO
BELIEVE IN FREE SPEECH IS ALL OF
A SUDDEN, MAN, THESE FOLKS ARE
CONSERVATIVE BECAUSE IT SEEMS
LIKE EVERYTHING HAS MOVED SO FAR
TO THE LEFT THAT IF YOU SAY
SOMETHING THAT'S A FACT, IT'S
LIKE, WOW, THAT PERSON MUST BE A
CONSERVATIVE AND SO MUCH
MISINFORMATION THAT THESE
COMPANIES SHOULD BE FINED.
SEAN: I'M NOT A MARXIST.
EVERYONE IS BEING A REPUBLICAN.
LARA: THIS IS THE FIRST TIME OF
FINE OR ELMORE.
JACKI: IT'S ALSO TRACKING,
TRACKING ALL THE TRANSACTIONS
AND KNOWING WHAT EVERY
INDIVIDUAL IN THE COUNTRY IS
DOING AND KEEPING TABS ON THEM.
THAT'S A LOT OF REASON CRYPTO IS
GAINING MOTEN TENTUM AS WELL AND
PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO GIVE THAT
INFORMATION OUT.
LARA: TO ME, THE MORAL HERE IF
THERE IS ANYTHING TO TAKE FROM
THIS IS THAT WHEN PEOPLE CALL IT
OUT, THEN THEY CHANGE COURSE.
YOU KNOW, I THINK ABOUT THE
DISINFORMATION CZAR, PEOPLE WENT
CRAZY OVER THAT BECAUSE IT'S
INSANE.
THIS IS TOTALLY UN-AMERICAN TO
HAVE, YOU KNOW, SOME RANDOM
PERSON DECIDING WHAT IS TRUE AND
NOT TRUE.
NO DIFFERENT HERE.
I THINK THE PUSHBACK ACTUALLY
CALLS ATTENTION AND MAYBE THAT'S
A GOOD THING WE NEED TO KEEP
THAT IN MIND.
I ALWAYS FEEL LIKE AS AN
AMERICAN.
THAT'S WHAT WE SHOULD DO.
SEAN: THIS IS THE EFFORT.
THEY'LL COME BACK AGAIN WITH
ANOTHER PROPOSAL TO SEIZE YOUR
MONEY IF THEY DISAGREE WITH WHAT
YOU SAY.
THEY GOT CAUGHT TODAY BUT
THEY'LL BE NEW SYSTEMS IN PLACE
TO TRY AND CONFINE WHAT YOU CAN
SAY PUBLICLY BECAUSE THEY WANT
TO CONTROL YOUR SPEE